les chéris il y aura quatre binômes et
on va démarrer avec maxime et le du lean
vous allez bosser les martys allez-y
vous aller patiner et vous aller patiner
sur quelle musique barça s'avoue lui ne
s'est pas d'accord c'est sur crise
ça
je vous veux
attention attention
[Musique]
ouais
sortez
sortez sortez gaza mais c'est une
catastrophe et on va voir les notes
rester chez ruquier survivants attendent
leur note va attendre leurs notes laisse
rester d'abord sur le sur les personnes
qui attendent les notes merci la gueule
alors les notes du jury
allez-y fixisme arrêter ses efforts
c'est maintenant ou jamais pour la
partie situation durant cinq heures
chacun boni donc on a la première note
du premier couple ondam enchaîner
maintenant avec ma deuxième couple c'est
bernard montiel bernard montiel
ah non il avec jean michel maire on va
le laisser encore s'échauffer on va
mettre le deuxième jeudi avaient demandé
qu'ils appellent et gilles de bien
vouloir se présenter
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr ils vont danser sur des
compagnons de la chanson
ils vont pas tirer sur eux
le générique ce de boby lapointe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention ma
attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après toi c'est beaucoup mieux que les
deux autres
merci de pas net de malabat avoue
isabelle hallé noter les seniors tout de
suite ce couple de seniors qui nous a
fait l'honneur d'être avec nous ce soir
vient pas lui apporter urnes ont porté
qui est assez spectaculaire menée 6
bravo s'amusent les normands c'est une
horreur alors cette donnée alors moi je
donne des poubelles ou parce que là il
ya des locales vraie prise de risque
moi je mets un ami
c'est vologe pour qu'on en arrive tous
mes amis et moi pour vous je mets à 5
sur 10 vraiment pas ce que vous allez
bien paquin et j'ai mis à tout à l'heure
au premier tour alors merci
attention on va enchaîner avec bernard
montiel et jean-michel mais le premier
pas de rival sons claquage en tout cas
vous le patinage la tenue patino monde a
extrêmement bien oui
alors prends pas le risque
attention c'est parti on y va musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un pont
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
afin d'y aller au match à l'aller
jean-michel allez allez bon match là-bas
pour attendre notre merci donnez moi ça
donc on remercie jean ville magnifique
et ils ont fait des efforts en soit
j'aime bien ils ont fait des efforts
attention ils attendent leur note bien
entendu heures était maire jean mi c'est
bien fait rire 3 3 joly j'ai eu un rôle
au coeur capella alors il ya une chute
insulté zone est trop d'erreurs 3 les
séries doit-on surtout beaucoup j'ai
trouvé je mets 6 pour jean ce temps jean
michel bernard jeu messi s'est arrêté de
jouer si vous aimez la viande est fort
différent ce qu'ils sont et c'est gilles
et isabelle et on va cueillir le dernier
coup benjamin castaldi et sa belle soeur
et sa belle soeur kelly mais nos maisons
[Applaudissements]
plutôt attention
[Musique]
il
hélas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sakho abidal fait quoi merci merci il
faut l'appeler folle finale dans un
caméra merci applaudissements poids
avant les séries bravo à l'égout à la
tante bolloc'h est pas mal du tout
benjamin castaldi et sa belle-soeur qui
ont tellement bien dense et attendent
leur note les cherise attendent leur
note merci à l'est merci merci merci
merci
c'est des téléspectateurs s'il vous
plaît pour castagner kelly qui vous
plaît pour castaldi était un excellent
8e les fans de michel aulas est qu un
excellent 8 alors jean michel merle a
laissé l'écart première fois une peau de
banane sur de la glace
combien il a jeté une peau de banane
pour les faire glisser sur de la glace
donc j'ai mis un bon set up
[Applaudissements]
c'était punchy
je vais vous dire pour ce couple qui a
été excellent excusez-moi eux
là vous êtes vous est dégueulasse
excusez moi de mon gars
l'intérêt pour ce couple qui a été
excellent jeu mais la note de 6
bravo à ces dons benjamin castaldi et
qu'elle uv novelli qui gagne le concours
de potinage bravo messieurs